historically speaking Prime Minister's
aren't food but this little fact wasn't
enough to stop those go getting Dutch
from chowing down on their own in 1672
now this raises a pretty obvious
question why why did the Dutch eat their
prime minister how does someone go for
being in a position of immense power to
becoming food for an angry mob so a bit
of background in the mid 17th century
the young Dutch Republic was in a
difficult situation it was surrounded by
hostile powers who were pretty keen to
carve it up or at least permanently
subjugated you see the Dutch Republic
was rich incredibly rich mostly due to
its near monopoly on trade with
Southeast Asia which everybody else
wanted having so many enemies meant the
war was somewhat inevitable so the title
of Prime Minister didn't exist back in
1653 in the formal head of the dutch
republic was called the stat holder
previously this office had been held by
the princes of orange and was
essentially an elected monarchy however
as of 1650 the office was left vacant
after a quarrel between william ii and
officials from holland in the decades
following this the country was deeply
divided between two political groups the
first group was the Status those who
favored a loose Federation and less
centralized power and the second group
were the orangist who wished for the
return of the monarchical system under
the house of orange in a deeply
centralised state without a stat hole to
the effective head of the country with
the grand pensionary of holland the
richest and most powerful of the united
provinces and the man who held this
position was johann davit defeat was in
many respects a moderate his primary
interest was protecting the flow of
Trade and thus he wanted to avoid war at
all costs as such Davitt prioritized the
creation of a strong Navy to deter
anyone from interrupting said trade now
this policy worked well initially when
England fought a war in 1665 to pry some
Dutch trade away from it the Dutch
promptly and decisively crushed the
English Navy after this Davitt was at
the height of his popularity in power
and so sought to use this to settle a
dispute with the oranges who were led by
the young William of Orange
as such he implemented a law which meant
that Holland no longer recognized the
officer stat holder making it impossible
for William to have control of the
entire country should he rise to power
to put it mildly this upset the oranges
but there wasn't much they could do yet
things went south in 1672 when King
Louie the fourteen for France decided
that the Dutch Republic existence had
gone on for a bit too long and so he
invaded and things went poorly
for the Dutch very poorly so much so
that 1672 is referred to as the ramp er
which directly translates to a year
which in retrospect can safely be
described as being pants with the French
army rampaging through the country the
oranges demanded of its head and made a
failed attempt to assassinate him he
resigned the office of grand pensionary
but this wasn't enough since he could
potentially return and so the orangist
arrested of its brother went of it went
to visit him he was ambushed and killed
by a mob and said mob subsequently ate
him and his brother not all of them that
would be uncouth but they did cook and
eat some of them we know this from
several sources who described it as
actually being a fairly organized
display of cannibalism which is pretty
rare in the end he was killed because
the people of his country were in a
state of raw panic and the Dutch mob ate
him because they hated him he had kept
their rightful monarch away from power
and so they sought to humiliate him in
death and in case you're wondering the
reaction to the deaths in the Netherland
was that it was justified in the
Neustadt holder William quickly pardoned
everyone so if you only take one thing
away from this when leaders messed
things up royally by losing a war and
alienating half of their own country
they move on to the list of things
eligible to be eaten something to
remember if you ever want to go into
politics I hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with the
special thanks to my patrons James
Bissonnette John lucid a man of culture
Danny Maloney little holiday John biz
guess rob Waterhouse MO James Castaneda
Aaron the white Jordan Longley Gustav
Swan
Marcus asana Rashid Ali spinning three
plates filled oink-oink David Silverman
Maggie packs Kowski Spencer Lightfoot
Lexi Schwinn Kelly moneymaker
Anthony Beckett Robert Wetzel Skye
Chappell Marvin Castle
Winston Hayward and Izzy